plus de 70% des avions du monde entier
sont cloués au sol
actuellement les livraisons de nouveaux
appareils seront réduits de moitié cette
année selon les estimations avec nous ce
soir fait les balducci qui est président
d'airbus canada qui fabrique la 220
l'ancien cseries
j'ai pas d'outil bonsoir bonsoir quel
est l'impact de la crise actuelle sur
airbus canada et sur la 220 c'est
l'impact d'abord de la crise
un peu comme pour tout le monde c'est à
dire qu'on a un accès on a eu pendant un
moment un accès très limité aux bureaux
et un autre outil production donc en
arrière on a arrêté
on a fait une pause dans notre dans
notre production pendant pendant sept
semaines puis on a repris en fonction
des contraintes qui nous était imposé à
micadanses et là on reprend
progressivement la production à plat et
on commence aussi à faire entrer des
quelques personnels de bureau qui
travaillent en très grande majorité
toujours depuis depuis la maison vous
avez réduit votre production de combien
alors on a on a réduit la production
d'abord encore une fois complètement
pendant pendant la période d'arrêt on a
repris ensuite à 50% et il a on a
environ serait de peu près 25 % de
réduction pour l'instant par rapport à
notre cadence initial sk des commandes
d'appareils à 220 qui ont été annulés ou
reportés
alors non on n'a pas de na pas de
commandes qui ont été annulés alors
ensuite évidemment tous nos clients que
la plupart de nos clients sont très
impactées et donc on a dix discussions
en permanence avec nos clients pour voir
comment accommoder au mieux les
livraisons on a par exemple d'aider des
clients qui ne peuvent pas venir prendre
livraison pour l'udc a en tout cas c'est
très compliqué de venir prendre
livraison d'appareils
il ya eu 350 mises à pied au début du
mois né à mirabel à quel moment ces
employés seront rappelés
alors effectivement vous avez raison on
a eu environ 300 un peu moins 350 mises
à pied temporaires qui était liée au
fait justement que ne pouvons pas
maintenir la production et on pouvait
reprendre camille capacités on a
commencé déjà rappelé environ un tiers
de ses employés
début juin au moment où justement n'est
plus cette restriction
et puis en fonction de la remontée de
cadence
on pense rappeler les personnels dans le
futur je peux pas vous donner de date
exacte
donc les 350 qui ont été mises à pied on
ne sait pas s'ils seront rappelés d'ici
la fin de l'année par exemple alors
encore une fois on en a déjà rappelé un
tiers métier voilà pour ce qui est du
reste on espère qu'on pourra les
rappeler d'ici la fin d'année soit
environ fière d'être encore certains
comme comment vole programme quelle est
la valeur du programme parce qu'on
entendait le premier ministre legault
récemment dire il va falloir radier
notre investissement qui ne vaut à peu
plus pop et plus rien monsieur fatigue
est bonne a dit la valeur de
l'investissement du gouvernement du
québec dans la 220 pique du nez
à combien que vous le programme
aujourd'hui à 220 donc c'est d'abord le
veulent
question que vous me posez régulièrement
d'ailleurs mais la valeur du programme
c'est ça dépend d'un grand nombre de
paramètres et surtout c'est une
c'est une vue que doivent avoir les
actionnaires donc évidemment le
gouvernement du québec en tant
qu'actionnaire tout à fait le droit
d'avoir sa vue et revue c'est également
aujourd'hui ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que l'avion lui-même est un avion
qui est très bien positionné justement
dans cette page de crise on souffre
comme tout le monde parce que d'abord
nos clients souffrent énormément donc
par évidemment on vient de parler de des
réductions de production convient
aujourd'hui donc nous souffrons mais
l'avion lui-même est un avion qui est
très très bien positionné aujourd'hui
c'est un des avions les moins impactées
en service on a à peu près au plus fort
de la crise on avait quand même à peu
près 40% que deux de nos avions deux
appareils qui qui était opéré
si je donne par exemple air canada ou
delta korean utilise 100 % de leur
flotte pas à pleine capacité évidemment
mais il 100% de leur flotte
on a aujourd'hui environ
plus de 75% de notre flotte qui volent
c'est pas hasard c'est parce que c'est
un avion qui est de plus petite taille
c'est un début c'est le plus petit
monocouloirs qui volent et qui est en
même temps traverse at il est donc il a
il à une performance économique y est
très attractive pour les pour les
compagnies et dans ces temps incertains
c'est certainement la note est
certainement un atout
vous avez raison cela dit le
gouvernement du canada on sent que le
gouvernement du canada hésitent à
appuyer l'industrie comme l'a fait la
france par exemple qui a injecté 15
milliards d'euros 23 milliards de
dollars canadiens
si le gouvernement du canada n'en fait
pas davantage
est-ce qu airbus pourrait décider de
délocaliser ou de rapatrier certaines
activités qui sont ici en europe ou
ailleurs aux états unis par exemple
alors je pense que vous avez vous avez
certainement raison que je vous rejoins
c'est à dire que l'industrie
aérospatiale et aéronautique civil est
une industrie absolument stratégique
le canada et le québec en particulier
est très bien positionné rappelle que
l'industrie aérospatiale et premier
exportateur du québec donc c'est une
industrie qui à la fois stratégique en
tant que intérêts presque souverain en
tant qu'expert en tant qu'exportateur
l'entente créateurs d'emplois qualifiés
donc c'est une scène c'est une industrie
qui est reconnu comme étant stratégique
par l'ensemble des pays quand la chance
d'en posséder une
performante c'est le cas aux etats-unis
c'est le cas en france et y en aura mais
c'est vrai qu'au canada cette voisine
d'ailleurs où les états se sont
positionnés pour pour soutenir cette
industrie s'est pas tout à fait le cas
effectivement au canada dans son
ensemble ou on n'a pas ce qu'on a eu des
soutiens on a bénéficié comme l'ensemble
des des industries des aides fédérales
mais on manque de signaux de signal fort
comme ceux de soutien à l'industrie et
donc ça pourrait changer quelques achats
chez rbs je pense pas que c'est comme ça
que ça ce qu'il faut réfléchir ça peut
changer des choses
dans l'ensemble sur la perception de
l'industrie et de la performance de
l'industrie aéronautique canadienne et
notamment québécoise aux yeux du monde
l'industrie aéronautique industrie
globale mondiale oui il est clair que
quand le est à l'arrêt au québec ou au
canada alors qu'elle peut fonctionner
ailleurs ça apparaît comme une zone à
risque pour l'ensemble des lattes de la
chaîne industrielle mondiale
bon je vous arrête si monsieur bal dj
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir c'est moi
merci beaucoup au revoir